welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the deaf night
and this video were breaking down some
exclusive leaks on the Batman that
confirm a lot about the movie every week
same bat-time same bat-channel we break
down all of the updates on the film and
these leaks add a lot of exciting
information to the production throughout
this video we'll be covering
confirmation of the Penguins role where
the movie is pulling inspiration from
and how we can verify these leaks of
what stars of the project have said
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want any of the reveals about
the film runed
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you drop a like to
help us spread the story and if you
enjoy this don't forget to subscribe to
the channel to never miss an update
without the way thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of the Batman leaks okay so I
just want to preface this with saying
that I get sent leaks like this on an
almost day to day basis if you've been
keeping up to date with the channel then
you'll know that this is the first time
I've run a story like this since
covering the Batman a triple check
everything with numerous sources and
other rumors to try and make sure that
I'm not misleading anyone or
deliberately trying to pull the wool
over people's eyes in order to get
clicks I always cite where information
comes from so that my viewers can see I
haven't just made it up myself and I try
to be as transparent as possible
I actually got sent this message on
Sunday and the reason I didn't instantly
run it is because I've been betting the
account making sure all lines up with
other leaks I have and that the name
they sent me is indeed part of the
production the message comes from
Twitter account Darkseid verse JLA and
I've been through their followers tweets
and what they've posted and so far I
cannot find anything to indicate that
just randomly throwing stuff out there
to try and build a wrap for themselves
so if this turns out to be untrue then
on my head be it now as for the message
itself I'm just gonna be reading it out
in its entirety and then breaking down
the information in it bit by bit
the message itself says I like your
videos young man and you put a lot of
work into them I'll throw you a bone my
friend and then they posted the person's
name works on these kind of movies winky
face and you're pretty close on your
story analysis for Batman vengeance the
Batman or whatever Reeves wishes to call
the story will hit on elements of long
Halloween as well as dark victory with a
bit of zero yeah thrown in
you already know those but the majority
of the story will come from Batman earth
one by Jeff Jones mare couple part etc
etc Pattinson was actually given this
book as a guide for the film an
amusement that he pointed out to me was
the up in arms fans when Pattinson said
he wasn't a hero
it was almost literally word for word
from the synopsis for the book on its
back cover
when Reeves threw out the Batman
benjin's name it's from a direct panel
in the comic itself where Batman first
confronts penguin and his office upon
his demise the Riddler
of course is the main antagonist with
his box of tricks from a thing it was
vol 2 anyway
the person's name gave me all of the
references that he knew of as he's an
old comic nerd too so you can either run
with this away for further info to leak
ok so there's a hell of a lot to impart
from that and as I mentioned earlier
we're just gonna be going through the
statements providing where they line up
and also discussing what it means for
the film in general I have asked the
user further questions and I definitely
trust the information and they've given
me
so the message starts off by saying that
the film maybe Batman benjin's but that
Reeves may change his mind as he seems
to be going back and forth on it and no
official statement from Warner Brothers
has been said about this early last
month an image from behind the scenes
showed rubber pattinson chair and on it
was splash the word vengeance we did
hear rumors that this was the working
title of the movie and it does look like
it could indeed be the name that the
film goes with as the account says
though we don't know this for definite
and it seems like Reeves is changing his
mind on it regularly however what is
interesting is like the post said this
is a big panel in the earth one graphic
novel as soon as I got this TM I went
and got my copy of earth 1 volume 1 and
flipped at the scene in which Batman and
his penguins office and there he was
walking into the room and saying
vengeance gave me goose bumps and either
the guy is telling the truth or he saw
the word vengeance on the chair then
remembered a specific panel in a Batman
origin story and sent me this message
just to get some attention now one of
the most interesting elements of Earth
one is that the penguin is the mayor in
it
the crime lord is pretty much leading
the crime wave in Gotham whilst also
ruling over it and this makes a breeding
ground for corruption light always rises
to meet darkness and because of this the
Batman is created we know from the leaks
on the project that the murder scene
that we saw with the news fans covering
it was for the assassination of the
mayor and that the characters funeral
will provide a big moment in the movie
we also know that Jamie Lawson is
playing a mayoral candidate named
Valerie Al so it does seem very likely
that Cobblepot will either take up the
position of the mayor in the wake of the
previous one's death or be in the
running for the role in the source
material Batman and it's some evidence
that shows Cobblepot may have caused the
death of his parents and whilst this is
eventually shown to be untrue we do
learn that he has killers working for
him the subplot of the earth one also
revolves around a mass murderer which
could be the position that the Riddler
takes up another thing that adds way to
the authenticity of the message is the
line about Batman not being a hero if
you cast your mind back to last year
when discussing the character Robert
Pattinson said the following Batman's
not a hero he's a complicated character
there was a lot of outcry on this and
Pattinson took a lot of shtick for it he
even had to apologize earlier this year
because a hell of a lot of fans were
stating that he just didn't understand
Batman at all because of it right after
I checked out the vengeance panel I then
turned the book over and on the back you
can clearly read the words Batman is not
hero so again either this guy is telling
the truth or he remembered a tiny line
in the synopsis on the back of a book
that just so happened to line up with
something that Robert Pattinson had said
no other fans notice this connection and
he just happened to then message me in
the hopes of getting mentioned in a
YouTube video again these are the
reasons why I trust the message and I
think that it's legitimate in the book
Alfred is also an army vet that but
grudgingly becomes Bruce's mentor and I
can definitely see Annie circus filling
this role if they decide to pull from
that depiction in the movie now before
we get into the rest of the video I just
wanna let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the Infinity Saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to being with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the links in
the comments
below the winners will be chosen at
random on the 15th of March in the cell
be shipped out from then Tova gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part ok so as for the comment
on the Riddler from the no more lies
picture that was leaked it does seem
like the villain will be operating
completely different to how we've seen
him before
if one volume one ends up with the
character being teased and he stands
there reviewing images of the Batman
before making his debut and volume 2 in
volume 2 Riddler is a terrorist and he
murders people in Gotham in the hopes of
getting Batman's attention
Riddler plants bombs in the city have
buildings on trains and more after going
head-to-head with him and being severely
injured Batman is rescued by Selina Kyle
who by the end of the book becomes the
Catwoman we have seen in the behind the
scenes shots that there is a point in
the movie where Catwoman is well not
Catwoman and the fact that she didn't
have a costume in the bike chase could
show that this movie is going to be an
origin story for her the message does
say that the work is also pulling from
the long Halloween and off victory and
both of those sent her around Catwoman
discovering her past and a killer and
Gotham that leaves clues behind for
Batman it is possible that the Riddler
is doing this instead of the bombings as
that bits more in with the typical
depiction of the character and the way
that he operates
Batman stops the Riddler at the end of
the book and in vol 1 Alfred shows up
and kills mayor penguin it is revealed
that penguin wasn't behind the death of
the Wayne's per se but that he did send
an assassin for them and then they just
so happened to stumble across the mugger
see ya if you want to know what's going
to happen in the movie I definitely
recommend that you pick up earth 1
volume 1 and volume 2 the phenomenal
stories and after rereading both since
getting this message
I definitely think they hold a lot of
weight with what we know so far about
the movie all in all I'm very hyped to
see the film after reading this message
and again I did vet the Twitter account
and after seeing how little random
tidbits lined up with what the user said
it does seem legitimate 0ya is also a
very Riddler centric story in which the
villain takes over Gotham and the bike
that we've seen used in images thus far
lines up a lot with Batman's mode of
transport in that so to summarize
everything the film is going to be
pulling from earth one long Halloween
dark victory and zero year to provide a
story the likes of which we've
scene on screen Robin appears in dark
victory and now have been getting
message leaks on the character possibly
being hinted at in the film this wasn't
part of the message hence why I'm not
really given it a big breakdown now if
you're a youtuber or news outlet and
decider in this story I ask that you
please source the channel and mention us
as it massively helps out I always give
shout out to where I get my information
from so with us leading on this story
and appreciate the same back I am
staying in contact with the user and
they have said that they will give me
any further updates that they hear about
so make sure you subscribe to the
channel to keep up to date with the
leaks as we get them
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these and what you want to see in the
film do you believe them do you not have
you heard anything else
yeah just comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
give it a thumbs up as it massively
helps the channel out and make sure you
check out our full breakdown of the fan
theories that we have on the film and
how we think things will play out in the
movie that'll be linked at the end so
definitely give it watch after this you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you get
access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way to helping videos like this get
made if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey poke the discord link
in the description below those are the
best ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]